the natasha romanoff that we knew
originally could still be alive going
into phase four the end of phase four
will be this like kind of New Avengers
versus Thunderbolts battle how did Bucky
become the white wolf you might ask well
maybe he stopped the taskmasters
assassination plot in the post-credits
scene of the Black Widow movie this is
rogue theory and we are talking about
the new black widow trailer but we're
also gonna talk actually about the movie
and it's getting close so we're gonna be
very careful actually Erik got really
close with some stuff in his recent
Russo breakdown you just pick it up too
close and there was a restraining order
filed yeah so we're actually gonna make
some theories that go beyond just that
movie and I'm excited to get into them
also we're gonna talk about some other
twists for some other versions of
storytelling the MCU I'm Phillip Malina
of course with me Erik Bosse hey
everyone Zack Charleston yeah
touchscreen Zack on screen on screen
said
I made it I'm so happy to be back thank
you for having me of course Tricia how
many of those dresses do you have yeah
my whole wardrobe is fun dresses and so
when I end up hosting or being on camera
for an outlet that's like no IP
whatsoever not even hinting at IP I'm
like the potato guys the final trailer
for Black Widow came out this week and
it hinted at a lot of stuff there was a
ton of new footage so we're obviously
pumped for this movie to come out in May
it's got this weird timeline is between
civil war and infinity war I don't
actually want to hear anymore GD
theories about what's gonna happen in
the movie because I think we're starting
to get too close but I actually am
excited about the post-credits scene I
had a realization this movie is like
kind of in a weird way almost like our
first real foray into phase 4 even
though it doesn't take place in phase 4
they gotta be setting something up for
where we're headed now this is gonna be
our first dip in for a long time pitch
me on the post-credits scene of Black
Widow and what it means for the larger
potato verse this is I'm excited about
this this is why off screen Zack had to
come on screen just to give this theory
here here's what what made the infinity
saga so much fun right is like these
little breadcrumbs that built up to the
the huge endgame right like payoff right
like a little like a little sneak peek
at this purple guy in space and like all
these Infinity stones keep popping up
here and there right so I think they're
gonna do that again for phase 4 and I
think it starts at the end of Black
Widow so like Black Widow plays out this
taskmaster bad guy you know he's doing
okay it's a bad stuff I hope it's better
than that I can picture the action
figures in your hands she defeats
taskmaster he goes to jail roll credits
boom end credits we we zoom in on the
top secret ultra high level prison where
test masters being held
and walking down the hallway is fattiest
Thunderbolt Ross played by William her
know he's in this movie right and he'll
be doing some matching Nations during
the movie maybe he's like a separate and
antagonist to Black Widow what level of
D aged William Hurd are we talking Oh I
mean just that sweet zone of like etat
54 you know and he's in the 60s now
right so like 10 years to get back but
some peppermint stache yeah a little
Botox he he faints of broadcast news and
he comes up to taskmaster cell Tony
masters has been there probably unmasked
at this point and it's Hawkeye and and
Thunderbolt Ross says I'm putting
together a team just like Nick Fury
Danny cuts there yes that's it that's
the end of it right and then we get
trickled out over the next couple phase
four properties and Disney Plus shows
some upcoming movies he keeps showing up
in recruiting people for the Thunderbolt
there you go that's a rogue II with
taskmaster just throwing out there you
know who is a member of the Thunderbolt
at times Yelena biloba yes
maybe maybe there you have side by side
cells and he looks at both of them and
says I'm putting together a team like
the Scarlet Witch oh can he be really
fast if he watches Quicksilver yeah I
think that's all it takes is just like
watching their video billionaire fee why
just Tony Stark yeah so and I think this
builds to the end of phase four much
like we got this giant war with a nose
for an end game the end of phase 4 will
be this like kind of New Avengers versus
Thunderbolts battle right there like we
can't do just like one super powerful
big bad guy uh but we can do team vs.
team and have like instead of the
battlefield of being a bunch of nameless
Thanos goons fighting are our friends
and it's like oh a bunch of bad guys we
recognize fighting a bunch
good guys we recognize I want you to add
something to the sixth I think that is a
very cool place for it to eventually get
it's almost another take on civil war
but where they do want to kill each
other yes
which might be put civil war is that
actually was smaller and scaled and it
could have been I but similar actually
so Thunderbolt Ross is potentially gonna
become Red Hulk and so it's better for
him to fight then like Jubilee from the
x-men in the comics Thunderbolt Ross
becomes Red Hulk right it's like it's
great to if you look at him of you still
kind of has the mustache and everything
but he's bright red instead of bright
green and he and you know there's all
kinds of storylines but he and Hulk
fight it would make sense we don't have
a planned Hulk still a movie yet rumor
has it he would just say yeah I know
that's probably the weird that way you
can da Jim to whatever yeah it can be De
Niro under there I read a rumor and it's
pretty I think like out there now I just
think it hasn't been officially
confirmed that Marvel did reacquire the
rights to the Incredible Hulk and can
now make a standalone Hulk movie yes
where they introduced the full team yeah
everyone's wondering why Ross is in this
movie anyway so there's Sun setting him
right there increasing him with my
addition to yours you get another rogue
II today yes yeah the three roadies
you'll get this episode you've got him
now could like maybe like love and
thunder the Thunder of that title is a
reference to the Thunderbolts and the
love
it can happen speaking of going negative
is next okay so I have my rogue theory
is that this end credits scene is going
to turn everything we know about the
infinity saga on its head and we will
find out that the natasha romanoff that
we knew originally could still be alive
pulling into phase four and this is how
it's gonna happen so Don you get a quick
Rogi because I'm not ready to let go of
ScarJo yeah despite what she screams
honestly I'm gonna say it could be
ScarJo and it could be Elena and I'm
saying that because in this last trailer
we saw right right we saw Elena strapped
down with a line up here right which
maybe could be a Face Swap plot going on
in this movie so it could turn out that
the natasha who came back in endgame who
was blonde who made comments to I
believe it was straight to cap saying
you know I never had a family before the
adventures could be Yelena taking over
Natasha's persona if you will and so
that maybe that's the Natasha who red
skull said Natasha son of Ivan because
she had taken on maybe the persona so I
feel look I think we're gonna get
something where the end scene is gonna
reveal that we have a potential ScarJo
in phase four okay so today this car do
you get that Rhodey back okay I think
she's I think she's still young I think
she's got a lot of superhero film life
left in her so why not use her info and
nothing we can't use a little woman in
some way she can be in the Thunderbolt
but I guess no that would have worked
where the character would be the one
behind the face the whole time you're
saying fruit right so I think the
natasha romanoff we we got to know in
the infinity saga all the way up until
let's say the redhead Natasha all the
way up until sabor maybe there was a
swap
yes which would be exactly when the
Black Widow movie is taking place but I
don't think we're gonna deal with that
as much in the actual film like we might
see a face swap but I think the actual
confirmation of PS natasha as we knew
her originally is here in five
for that that will be the post-credits
scene because we need something that's
gonna make everyone go when we put a
film in the middle of a timeline that we
already know what are the stakes right
that's always the problem with the Han
Solo solo film you know like all that
kind of stuff the stakes are when we
know what's coming after this so how
much can they really make us feel like
actually did try that with adding Darth
Maul that's right we're just like we
need something that changes everything
as we know I like this too because it
also changes the way we perceive movies
that have already happened right you'll
you'll have to go and like we watch
infinity war an end game and be like oh
you know but to be clear original black
widow is still the one that tickled Hulk
right yes only one person can do that
weird you know but yeah I don't want a
lot of people are hoping that they bring
back ScarJo yourself included in phase
four but I don't want it to be some kind
of thing where it was time meddling with
Pym particles or something like actually
done or that she didn't actually die
right exactly because I feel like to a
lot of us that really felt Natasha's
death that would feel a little cheap
mm-hmm
someone had to die to get that soulstone
exactly but it was it and if we have in
the Black Widow solo film if we have
that which I'm still not convinced that
the Black Widow solo film is only gonna
be one film we might we might get a two
and three maybe somewhere down the line
all in the same all in the same time
period
I mean Iron Man guy three solo films
like with a trilogy it could all take
place there and it could be with ScarJo
and I think of that end scene it can set
that up for all of us very cool I do
want to go back to one part you're
saying cuz it's important to acknowledge
I think someone's already writing a
comment about it probably posted it so
when she goes and speaks to red skull on
Boromir he says Natasha son of Ivan I
know you're just it's really quick but I
want you to go do it again okay so he is
confused or he's wrong or he's right in
some weird way okay I have a theory
about that so I think it's that Natasha
Romanov the idea the persona of Natasha
is much like a James Bond
where lots of different people can take
on the name because it's really more of
like a title or a persona than it is her
specific like she was never given name
well no but I mean she was never named
Natasha by her parents I mean she she
was given that name later in life so who
really is Natasha son of Ivan and what
does that mean to be Zack it could be
yeah which one do I shoot though but so
that's why I think red school would say
that because we don't know we don't know
what her parent given name at birth she
was like an orphan and rescued from a
burning building no real parents died
and she was immediately brought into
like the system so they gave her the
name of Natasha right so how many other
people or clones or you know could they
have given so so yelena theoretically
also does not have a real true name so
then this is kind of the equivalent of
her name now or her soul's name yes
that's that's what I'm going with okay
gotcha all right that earned one extra
quarter Rogge Erik you might maybe he'll
lose it here it's steal it back yeah
what are the rules you steal it back by
adding to someone else's theory one
might be if you can reach the rogue it's
yours
it's like spoons okay so I think the
biggest reveal in this latest Black
Widow trailer was that taskmaster has
these like vibranium tight claws at the
end of his tips which we spotted in past
promos it's real quick why why do you
think those are definitely vibranium
well why would you put just like
aluminum claws at the end of your I mean
they could be adamantium there's
something strong because otherwise
they're not really effective so and not
only is it just closet like looks like
gloves it looks like a vibranium weak on
his fingertips that produces those
protrusions I like we're gonna make sure
so it probably is real vibranium that's
what I think also
because it looks like he has actual
spider-man webbing that he's strings
from like this guy not only just has the
skills he has the equipment to pull off
these Avengers copycat moves so the big
question I think from that part of the
trailers where did he get that vibranium
because it's not easy to come by you
have to have a connection to Wakanda to
get it and then one thing that I pointed
out is one of these Red Room assassins
looks like she might have somewhat
conned in tribal scarring I saw that we
can show an image on screen yeah and I
think a theory that I find interesting
is you see these like Red Room maps of
different world locations I feel like we
might see kind of like a sleeper cell
operation where they implant someone
from each country into a scenario where
they can assassinate someone who's
important to that country so what if the
big reveal that the trailers have been
really hiding from us from Black Widow
is that we're gonna have a Wakanda and
subplot now this is set in the years
from 2016 to 2018 right and Bucky is
going to be in the next thing to come
out after Black Widow Falcon Winter
Soldier it's gonna be his story where
was he during this time he was in
Wakanda he was in his rehab getting Dee
brainwashed and they gave him this
nickname of the white wolf now white
wolf is a different character Marvel
Comics but we never really understood
what his whole story was for those two
years in Wakanda so what if the
post-credits scene of Black Widow shows
us what Bucky's story was as a white
wolf helping Wakanda save itself from
itself though she went against a not an
intruder but a sleeper some kind of
internal threat that would that climbed
up the ranks of the dorm Alizee that was
within striking distance of the throne
of Wakanda and Bucky as someone who was
a brainwashed assassin could recognize
that helped them see a Russian asset we
see all of that in the post-credits
scene or we see that teased and then
we'll see that in the upcoming movie I
think that's going to be teased in the
post-credits scene and we're gonna see
that flashback in Falcon Winter Soldier
so this is a Black Widow trained agent
is pretending to be a member of the
Durham Laza and she is revealed in the
post-credits scene she's gonna try to
take out
T'Challa or I think it's just going to
be revealed late in the movie that there
is someone in every country at some
point you're going to
Condon math and you're gonna connect it
like oh that what kind of T'Challa is
under threat right now but we are going
to see that go down but flashbacks and
yeah you're gonna see the post grading
is going to be Bucky and Natasha
discussing what Bucky's next move is
gonna be
he doesn't have his new vibranium arm
yet because he's still in Wakanda and
he's like don't worry I'm on it
and I think the big thing that I'm
excited to see being answered is like
what changed in Bucky's mind during that
period in Wakanda and I think it's gonna
answer some questions about why he was
okay with letting Sam get the shield at
the end of endgame but why he also feels
like he deserves some recognition
because I feel like we're gonna see how
but he earned that title of the white
wolf and why he's so well-respected in
Wakanda
yes Sam we've seen every reference every
time Sam has fought we've seen him be on
the right side of things and he's
essentially an Avenger he is an Avenger
corn cat so he's kind of earned it and
and actually like Falcon having the
shield but people have always had
trouble saying well Bucky is probably a
lot more capable but he hasn't really
done anything to earn it and you're
saying we get flashbacks up yeah except
for save Wakanda that's actually a
pretty contentious fight over who
actually now is earned it yeah yeah I
love the idea of seeing Bucky in this
kind of Black Widow
verse as we're seeing it and it also
really makes me think we're getting more
than one black widow movie because it
would be so awesome to see Bucky's
backstory in the Red Room where he was
also brainwashed and how that happened I
want that story I love that well and I
think what we might see her these
flashbacks drained at Falcon Winter
Soldier of like what Bucky did to save
this like this nation and work with them
and like rise at the ranks but like he's
not well respected here and maybe in
Black Panther too coming to May 20-22
we're gonna see like Bucky rejoined
wakandan Society as someone who like is
like their chief intelligence officer -
and we're gonna see like a Bucky - chala
team-up that's pretty cool so Eric
obviously you've earned two more roadies
I'm gonna throw out that when we're
talking about a black widow in the Red
Room when we're talking about Bucky
we're talking about these people we're
talking about a lot of times attempts to
recreate this Super Soldier Serum with
the Black Widow team they had their own
smaller version I tried to use but not
the same thing but all of these like
potential serums and testing going on in
Russia
maybe that still leads to what Zacks
talking about about Red Hulk
yeah supposed to be a bastardized
Superman - yeah and it could be a
justification for future villains that
join the Thunderbolts or whatever -
right yeah I'm feeling it give them give
all your theories back to me in a tweet
mmm okay and in in memory of former
champion Tommy Bechtold I will be
rhyming still alive
Thunderbolts ad villain bulk led by Ross
as Red Hulk
Tommy Vettel due to some serious face
swapping surprise ScarJo natasha is back
and here for phase 4 yeah serious face
swapping this time not that pizza sauce
no we're gonna we're gonna peel off your
face Arya Stark
how did Bucky become the white wolf you
might ask well maybe he stopped the
taskmasters assassination plot in the
post-credits scene of the Black Widow
movie coming May first get your tickets
now this is a sponsored tweet guys real
quick I just want to do a quick shout
out to our discord we have a now channel
that is functioning as the rogue theory
Channel yeah and on that channel it's
not just to talk about
and criticize and attack and hurt our
feelings it's it's for all kinds of
things it's so you can play rogue theory
on that channel we just John just added
a bunch of rogue ease that get awarded
by vote from the rest of the channel
we'll have a couple of selective players
every week zach is heading that up he
just found out on Fridays this road
comes out Thursday the the video and
then on Fridays will kind of like
declare winners within the discord
channel so get in there for Thursday
Friday
you know vote pitch oh yeah minder ID to
become a member of our discord we're
honestly it's learned it's like the nerd
community that you have been searching
for it is you just have to be a patron
that's it if you're a member of our
patreon and at any level you have access
to our discord yeah so check that out
guys
I'm very excited about something that is
taking a little bit of an idea Eric was
talking about last episode a big
question about these immersive you just
want cross eyed for they pointed right
at me Eric was talking about this idea
of these immersive experiences crossing
over movies maybe now being things that
you have to go attend at a certain
facility because there's much more to
the 4d side of the experience but we
kind of do have a guaranteed version of
that coming soon to Disney parks because
they are bringing the Avengers facility
like a training facility there they've
been talking about a lot recently
so this Avengers campus we know a lot of
our favorite MCU characters are gonna be
there weirdly we know that dead
characters are going to reappear there
it's mostly gonna be dead people from
your past but so it has the you know
kind of a Harry Potter Park quality but
also specifically galaxy's edge we know
is canon and this is where we get to our
theories what story is going to happen
inside of the Avengers part of the park
that is going to be canon is gonna be
relevant to the MCU but also how do you
experience it what do you do as part of
contributing to the MCU let's go right
okay I'm really gonna go rogue with this
one because here's it's confusing
because they say it's not gonna be MCU
Canon but they believes the multiverse
to explain it so like the multiverse
kind of makes everything in the world
canon any world that we've seen from the
sony spider-verse to the simpsons
universe can now fit in the mcc MCM yeah
a whole universe it's just because
hawkeye stole that glove in an end game
when he trip time travel that's split
off all ruined everything they did not
put that glove back they didn't take the
gauntlet that's another glove right yeah
so what if like Disneyland's avengers
campus is actually like another
dimension within the multiverse but it's
a place where everyone goes when they
die and it's no just go away on this
it's like this joke they don't say death
they don't say like afterlife or heaven
or anything like that but it's hinted
like look this is just a hypothetical
the good place if you will so wait you
have to die to go there if you're there
you're dead like everyone there isn't
it's a happy place where it's a paradise
at people to center and everyone who you
like whether they be living or dead
currently in the MCU the living world
they're all here they're happy they're
just it's a paradise it's like they all
everyone is there even though like maybe
didn't get there the same time right
right I'm picturing a fan OHS that sits
at the entrance and just snaps as people
are walking it's like you're literally
you're walking into Frontierland and you
get snapped and you show up yeah yeah
the country Bear Jamboree came to life
now you are in Avengers campus cuz
usually I just finished watching the
good place I loved it and their version
of paradise is like kind of this
philosophy lecture right it's the idea
of trying to continue to improve the way
you see ethics and morality and and and
understand and process the experiment
called life that you just went through
and what is of interest campus it's an
educational experience to learn how to
be an adventurer to learn how to be a
hero how to be a better person and
that's their imagined idealized
afterlife is like what if I were to die
and
move on to Disneyland's of interest
campus I'd be a very happy and grateful
man so what is the story
well the story as you go there is just
like Doctor Strange kind of vaguely says
like what if there exists a dimension of
the multiverse where every good thing
can exist together in one place at the
same time we weren't thinking about
timelines we're not thinking about cause
and effect we're not talking about past
battles it's just like all the people
you know are together and we're trying
to work together to to improve ourselves
and it's not necessarily about like
what's the big fight it's just about
like let's hang out you know
I'm a nice happy place our making a mini
where's there
homer and Marge are there to a kylo
ren's gonna run through everybody not
slavery because it's heaven they're
sitting on your park bench with you just
like eating cotton closest showing you
what's in that steel he was making at
the beginning game just to see who had
to see any kind of fighting from these
characters fighting Lee P energy its
LARPing it's like we're fighting but we
all know it's all just kind of fun
remember we did this bad guys yeah well
taskmasters there but he's allowed to
get in just because he's like he's
LARPing - he's LARPing as the Avengers
he's trying to do their moves well we
also don't know who's underneath
taskmasters mask so it could be someone
that we like his mask is just could be a
mirror and it's gonna be your own face
master trying to have master these pants
down where's credit scene photo where
it's just like they make the screen
reflective and the audience watching
we're all tiny little people and people
get blinded cuz the projector why is he
naked in there he just it's too high
Eric
that is pretty rogue you my friend get a
quarter road no one wants The Avengers
to not fight in heaven $300 for that
ticket to sit at a birthday party we're
like a goofy yes like hero shows up and
says I'd pay 300 party Avengers themed I
love I love the feel good idea of it but
Disney's never gonna kill all their Park
yes to enter that part of the play I
won't use the words but you reap it on
the rise agree with you on at some point
they just do inch by inch until
eventually it's like yeah Disney can
kill me I want to but I keep noticing
I'm like you know I don't mind the
Disney owns box and this and this cuz
like now I finally get that story and I
finally get the end I'm like well when
am I gonna stop and realize like oh it's
too late they own everything including
me and then they killed me and as an
adult you're like cool I'm cuz I want to
get the rest of story but I'm thinking
of like the four year olds they just
want to be Iron Man you're not gonna
tell them when they come of age in a few
years they blend it with cocoa and then
we all just get skull candy made me to
tell me I've been dead the whole time
you say yes my child okay
so weird as hell Eric but I'm alright
with it
who's next what's gonna happen story
wise in this park and how do we
contribute apparently by dying is an
option okay I feel like I'm probably
gonna get the award for the most obvious
answer but it's called
Avengers campus mmm-hmm so it's probably
a school or instructional area so what
if dr. strange created a small little
dimension just for the purposes of
training new Avengers for all over the
multi-dimension a pocket dimension for
all over the multiverse because we need
new adventure avengers everywhere to
battle evil wherever it might be and now
they've already said that taskmaster I
think is gonna be like the villain of
the overall area which is perfect
because taskmaster has his
what's the word for it his reflexes his
photographic reflexes yes so he can take
on any of the heroes that he's seen in
action so whether you want to combat
against a Spidey Spidey type villain or
whether you want to combat against a
chala type villain or whatever it is
that you want to compat against you can
get that experience in the park and you
can train along with your favorite
Avengers that we know from the Infinity
Saga from MCU
teaching you how to become your own hero
and become your own Avenger
that's such a Disney yeah way to go that
anyone can be a hero and as far as like
rides we've already seen Disney pair up
with void VR for the stormtrooper
experience in Star Wars so I could
definitely see a void VR type of
training experience where you get to
walk through and feel it maybe with like
a haptic feedback vest or something like
that and since you're since you would
have a VR helmet
you could be right alongside your
favorite event or maybe even choose
which avenger you want to be your mentor
and well right because this is dr.
Strange's avengers campus where you're
learning so it's not it's not even an
idea of who's dead where are we in the
timeline who's about to die because I
honestly I don't think Disney would
touch that with a ten-foot pole if
they're talking about kids
I think the Disney message is you can be
a hero so much like the Jedi training
academy you can be a Jedi they could do
some kind of Doctor Strange you know you
can wield your power type show and we
know that it's taking over where bug's
life was so there's that big theater and
there with already everything meant to
make you feel miniature for bug's life
how easy would it be to port that to
ant-man so he's visiting all of their
world maybe what kind of akanda is a
world that you get to go
Avengers campus a multiverse of madness
where they're all actually yes there are
many similarities between I also like
and similar in both your theories
pushing yours just this thing we're like
dr. strange it takes him so so seriously
is also though like welcome to dr.
strange avengers emporium dr. strange
still being very serious like kind of
you like you encounter the very very
serious characters in galaxies edge
right now I see a very serious dr.
strange that's not like data doesn't
that come here and train he's like this
is a very important mission yeah we need
Avengers all over the multiverse and
you're the one can you made enough
cotton candy so you're gonna get a full
Rogi for that that's literally if they
don't use that idea they're missing out
that is such a great here's the thing
it's you're like oh it's the most
obvious may be training is kind of
obvious but the idea that you have
you're in a pocket dimension that has
segments to it of everything we've
experienced in the MCU maybe you can
replay previous battles and like great
fights you can try to race against Black
Panther and Captain America it's great
too because like it works
Disneyland is always aimed at both like
adults and and children and that works
on the children level of like I get to
train with black panther but also works
on the adult level of like it kind of
like justifies why these characters are
together and what the meta storyline
really appeals to adults and I also hope
that they keep the reality of like if
you are you know trying to fight baños
or something but you are a little kid he
just kills you couldn't you fail and
you're just dead and then we're in
heaven it's the good place and it's a
way to justify all these I think they're
gonna hire people to play visitors
grandparents yeah they could say
everything to them that uh that they
wish they'd been to that weird indie
play and we could talk about that Zach
can you defeat these okay so this was
that was the absurdist one that was what
the very profitable smart one this is
the comic book nerd one so like I grew
up early 90s
I'm 48 years old and one of my favorite
storylines
at the time was so absurd was the
Beyonder storyline battleworld yeah yes
right and it's the idea is is crazy they
were doing some crazy stuff in the late
eighties early 90s but is this crazy
powerful intergalactic guy basically
just stole all the superheroes
in the Marvel Universe and brought them
to his planet and made them fight that
was it he was just like this kid's dream
yes crazy powerful alien and that's what
he decided to do with this power you
wanted to see a spider-man fight the
thing or whatever right and so what a
great justification maybe it's the
beyond or maybe it's a similar character
maybe it's a character they invent for
Disneyland where he's like I've
assembled all of every character you
know from the past from the future good
guys bad guys whatever for this kind of
battle royale and then you as a park
visitor are helping Thor Black Panther
whoever trained to fight each other and
and the reason I'm saying that is
because though we know taskmaster is
gonna be in this park you know nobody's
favorite Marvel characters are the bad
guys
we love the good guy right people if you
were eight years old on the playground
you're not like I'll be Baron Zemo and
you know everybody's like I'm Thor
you're Captain America you're Black
Widow right yeah we want to be Iron Man
and so it's like Oh even better get to
see the fight Iron Man good to see you
Black Panther fight whatever I like in
this kind of like you know separate
reality battle royale style right yeah
I'm a big fan of wrestling WWE they
often you know they have the good guys
in there bad guys you have to just throw
that out the window when it's time for
like Royal Rumble or whatever right it's
like it's every man for himself I love
that idea
yeah squeeze that into the first
Avengers right like Thor was fighting
iron man iron man was fighting cap like
this ya know I also love this I do think
it's funny that I think you mentioned
quickly that visitors help the heroes
train for their
it's like the leave nine-year-olds like
I've started karate yeah yeah let me
show you how to punch Bucky or whatever
school no pills I'm on the spot no it's
like Tinkerbell rules it's like okay
this going you've got a wish for Ironman
to win this fight get a real homies that
Homer is always there
all right guys come back to me in a
tweet real quick Zack did earn a full
row Gabriel
okay
Disneyland is opening the pearly gates
to the Disney verse but you can talk to
grandma and sing remember me from cocoa
to her and you both cry kylo Ren I will
not run this one how about like all your
favorite heroes fight each other and you
can help the multiverse needs new
Avengers and we need you literally it's
coming out of the Disney account
Cumberbatch tweet that I'm just gonna
award right here at the end just of all
these tweets
Tricia's was definitely the best
delivered but I actually want to go to
his ex parte Tommy you're doing great
[Laughter]
anything could change although Eric did
stack is higher so use point two-five
ahead alright you guys ready for these
yes okay there you go all right guys
there's now a Justice League branded
protein powder what would Batman taste
like as protein powder what would Batman
taste I guess protein powder dark
chocolate salty yeah I think Batman's
protein powder is just the cremated
ashes of the way that
and Disney has revealed that the villain
of the upcoming Disneyland adventures
campus will be Black Widow villain
taskmaster what fake super villain would
be the worst to encounter at Disneyland
as in who is your Disneyland villains
the line cutter it's we got a family of
12 and you were paying attention because
you were looking at the art in the line
for the New Avengers ride
we're sneaking in there brother would be
like permanent crying child like always
standing in front of you in line always
crying
yeah that's your villain is just a sad
child that's a lot about needs a lot of
health clearly and he just keeps crying
innocent innocent person it's more about
me and my judgement yeah okay I'm going
with the actual scary thing at
Disneyland we'll call them the the
stroller stalker or dumb maybe I don't
know this is gross a stroller stalker
I'm not thinking of it in a pedo way I'm
thinking it in a kidnapping way oh I
wasn't gonna pet away they're like
they're gonna take your kid maybe I
assumed when you said that it's just
somebody that followed like walks right
behind you with a stroller and rollers
bad the worst stroller and I say this as
a parent that's when it is Neyland are
the people that cut you off with the
strollers when you're walking and then
like a stroller just yeah I was in New
York City bagel shop last week and
somebody those are tight spots with long
lines and somebody was in there with a
stroller trying to navigate it and
everybody was mad at the baby baby was
like hey I'm gonna stroll
look I need my morning bagel just like
you do I wanted everything baby Wang
Ultra Music Fest in Miami was cancelled
due to coronavirus surprisingly my name
is big fan of corona though
can we make some electronic music to
make it up for the fans that no longer
stay home just because I really enjoyed
having you on here and I want you to
come back desperately we're gonna give
you two because honestly both of her
pitches were very good you don't have to
throw me the win but I appreciate it
because now I get my wishes okay let's
see everyone else has to sign off in
their best Russian accent okay da that's
it that's it for this episode of road
theory thanks for going rogue with
[Music]
somebody please take this weekend on new
rock stars YouTube channel we will have
a MCU cosmic power level rankings and
feel Melina and I at the a possible will
break down which characters are more
powerful than panels these are their
Eternals
could they beat him in on wrestling you
tell us you tell us but the
[Music]
in Mother Russia
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]